hey guys it's joanna here something i've
always emphasized over and over again is
a short workout is better than no
workout so if you only have 15 minutes
in the morning you can still get your
workout done i want you to start
marching on the spot to get your body
warmed up i've designed this workout to
be low impact so you can get this
workout done in your pajamas there are
seven exercises okay each workout will
be for 45 seconds long with 15 seconds
rest in between and the goal is to
complete two sets
kick start your metabolism first thing
in the morning and you will be burning a
lot more calories throughout the day and
i can assure you you will have a more
productive and stronger day ahead so
let's do this
so i'm going to set my timer i want you
to give me your very best shot okay we
want to work the entire body from the
lower body to your upper body and to
your abs alright so we have 15 more
seconds and we want to get straight into
the workout the first workout is going
to be new to squat pulses so start lower
down i want you to lean back slightly
and get up
and get into squat pulses okay four
times and get back down ready
and let's go lean back tighten your core
come back up and pass one two three four
nice
knee back down lean back really lean
back tighten those core back up
one two three four nice back down lean
work those abs wake those muscles up
one two three four this is also a really
good way to really wake the entire body
up up stay low one two three four do not
come higher okay again lean back tighten
the score up
one two three four keep low one last
time come on
keep your body strong keep your core
tight back up really feel the slick
muscles push your butt back
and rest
second workout alternate lunge touch
down okay so start forward take one step
back touch down back up and touch down
all right three more seconds let's go
down look straight ahead down so i want
you to bend your knees keep them 90
degrees
and lunge down okay
your knees should almost touch the floor
but without touching the floor come back
up nice touch
keep your body upright chest open and
touch good keep going
lunge push your butt back feel your legs
working for your butt working for your
hamstrings working and remember to pace
your breathing nice chest up do not lean
forward chest up and just tap
down gently 10 more seconds
last two
keep going last one
breathe out and rest next workout hops
and push up so we want to work on our
upper body now so
get onto the mat
start in a push-up position all right i
want you to hop in
out
one push-up okay ready let's go
in out
push up nice
if you can't do it on your toes get onto
your knees push up hop in out knees push
up
very good hop in out challenge yourself
get onto your toes
nice
when you hop in engage your core
and work those abs as well good keep
your body straight
do not
arch your back
and just keep your body straight and
look
gently down nice
give it a good
deep hop
good few more
keep those upper body strong come on
guys i know you're feeling your muscles
burning one last push-up
and
rest it out
my heart rate is pumping
i'm feeling tired but i know i'm going
to start my morning really strong
next workout cross plank jacks okay so
again start in a push-up position
two jacks okay cross over
two jacks good
cross
and two jacks again this workout is
working on your upper body
and also your abs cross
keep your body straight
do not push your butt too high up okay
halfway there
two plus jacks cross
cross feel obliques working
to jax cross
cross
remember to breathe do not hold your
breath
keep breathing
cross
cross and one last one
cross
cross
two more
and
rest it out
so you should feel your legs working
your upper body working and we're not
done yet we're halfway there i want you
to get into dwarfing planks right now
okay
so
start in a plank position stay low
okay what i want you to do is go over
your fingertip push up into
sort of like
a downward dog forward
and push your butt up you should really
feel your arms working your shoulders
your triceps
so these are really slow movements
but it's gonna really work on your upper
body muscles
up push your butt up
feel your core engaged
over your fingertips
push up nice
over
keep going
up
keep those plank strong okay up
last one more
and
rest it out
stay with me guys two more workouts and
you will get a one minute break okay
groin is next so same thing into a plank
position you can choose the simpler
version
which is to step forward
look up back step forward look up and
back okay
so that's
an easier
version really feel your lower back
stretched out if you want to challenge
yourself
then let's get into
plyo
groiners hop it out
good hop
whoa
pacy breathing
oh
i can see
my sweat
dripping on the mat
but i know
that it is my fat crying keep going guys
feel those bad muscles working feel
those leg muscles working
your low back engaged and your abs okay
give me two more
last one
wrap it up
oh
one final workout okay
half of the touch to knee touch so
i want you to sit back
onto your mat
i'm gonna wipe my sweat support your
upper body with your hands
okay give me a solid knee tucks extend
half detox and knee tucks okay extend
straight
and in
and up good
small movements but you will really feel
your abs working up
in
and up good keep going guys feel more up
knee in
i can feel my lower and my upper abs
burning whoa
come on keep going do not stop now 15
more seconds let's go up
in
up oh my god in
up
in
and up
10 more seconds if you need to bend your
knees slightly okay up
in
rest it
out
very very
very well done so now you have a one
minute break
grab yourself some water keep yourself
hydrated
wipe your sweat
and we want to do the entire workout
once more for the second set okay so
stand up
shake your lips a little bit
keep yourself hydrated and wipe your
sweat
good job second set soon
all right guys you have about 20 seconds
left okay so we want to get into the
second set you know all the workouts
right now i want you to give it your
best shot
at as many reps as you can within the
given time but do not sacrifice proper
form okay to really work on targeting
the right proper muscles all right so
let's get back down onto the mat at the
first workout is going to be a new two
squat passes three seconds left and
remember we want to lean back let's go
lean back up
and one two three four small pulses down
lean back tighten those abs pull
yourself back up
one two three four good back down
remember suck those abs in as far as you
can
and up nice
small pulses but really effective work
on your hamstrings your quads and also
your glutes up
one two three four okay remember to push
your butt back all right back
push your butt back do not hunch forward
do not collapse one two three four very
good last one lean all the way back up
really feel those quads one two three
four good
rest it out second workout get back up
alternate lunge touchdown okay so start
in the center
and we want to lunge back and touch down
okay so the opposite side three more
seconds
let's do this let's go touch down look
straight ahead touch down nice look
straight touch
knee almost touching the floor and push
up with your heels back up
good
very good guys
keep going
alternate sides
nice lunge all the way down legs 90
degrees
bring your knee almost touching the
floor feel your legs burning see your
muscles burning
those pain
are good pain okay
keep going 15 seconds left
nice
do not stop now
keep your breathing going pace your
breathing
in through your nose
out through your mouth
last one more
and
the other side
rest it out
next workout we want to focus on our
upper body and also our core
so hops
and push up
breathe in breathe out
let's get on to
a plank hops in out
push up good
in out
push up again beginners
if this is difficult get onto your knees
and slowly progress from there knees
push look straight ahead
in and out okay
very good
all right
if you can challenge yourself
and slowly get onto your toes small hops
are really crunch your abs in
and feel your abs working good
keep going
whoa
i can feel my upper body
burning my chest muscles
working
last one
and
one more push-up
ah
rest it out
fourth workout cross plank jack okay
so again it's all about working the
obliques upper body
and also just the entire mid section
three seconds let's go
whoa
two
plank jacks cross over
nice two
keep your upper body strong
steady
keep your back flat
and cross
good
now keep going
[Music]
cross good
breathe in
gaze down gently
and just feel your abs
and your arms
burning at the same time
i can see my sweat dripping it is all
good
you're gonna feel so amazing
right after this let's do it
last one cross
cross
and
rest it on oh my god three more
exercises okay
dwarf in plank
will really focus on the triceps and the
shoulder muscles okay
slow movements but really focus on the
upper body let's do it get into a plank
go over your fingertip push up
into a high downward stop
over
down low
up into a v
opposite v
up
and push
i am sliding because of my sweat
keep going guys
stand tall
on your toes push up
feel
your arms
as you go over
your fingertips
nice
breathe
almost there three more seconds
last one
rest it out
groin this okay
so
this is one of my favorite workouts
but it is one of the toughest so you
have an option to either do a beginner
workout or the harder version okay
so
let's go start
and hop good hop look up hop
oh my god
your legs your butt
and your upper body supporting you
good pace your breathing
keep going
again beginners if this is tough you can
always take a step back
back
forward
back
forward okay
follow your pace
and eventually
challenge yourself
and push
good few more
[Music]
10 more seconds
second last workout do not stop now
if you can see your start dripping on
the floor
remember to keep
pushing
yourself
one
final
workout
half
detox to knee tucks
oh i am absolutely naked
oh who says a 15 minute workout is
simple
it is not okay
right let's go
knee talks
and a detox okay
good if you need to bend your knees you
can bend your knees slightly okay up
in
up
[Music]
keep going guys he tucks in do your
upper abs and your low abs working
last workout keep going 10 more seconds
this is not easy but you got this all
right five more seconds
last one
and
[Music]
rest it
out
ah
that was
two sets in 15 minutes
well done guys very well done now you
can start your morning
full of energy and sweat
guys i am absolutely sweaty it wasn't an
easy workout but i'm feeling really good
so your challenge for the next six weeks
is to stay active on a daily basis no
matter how short it is if you stay
consistent if you build a consistent
routine i can assure you you will start
to lose weight and also tone up
so if you enjoyed this workout be sure
to like this video challenge your friend
to start their morning with this workout
share this video and subscribe to my
youtube channel for more fitness videos
healthy and really easy recipes and also
nutritional tips all the best